ces patients sont les plus gravement
atteints de lakovic 19 portées par une
deuxième vague de l'épidémie qui frappe
la france de plein fouet
il échoue ici leur corps secoué par le
rythme saccadé des respirateurs
artificiels une bouée de sauvetage pour
certains mais un patient sur quatre ne
sortira pas envie de la réanimation
erwan l'air dirige l'unité de
réanimation du centre hospitalier de
brest en bretagne et il le constate la
région tout à l'ouest ne peut plus
compter sur son isolement naturel pour
se prémunir les coronavirus on est on
est vraiment qui alors dès le début
alors déjà par rapport à la première
crise ou clairement la bretagne a été
vraiment épargné la deuxième vague va
vraiment nous arrivait de plein fouet et
puis de toute façon même si elle ne nous
arrive pas compte tenu de la gravité de
la situation dans certaines régions on
va être obligé forcément d'accueillir
des évacuations sanitaires
parce qu'on peut pas laisser les
collègues du jeune régions françaises
dans cette situation là s'il règne
encore ici un calme relatif
l'unité a malgré tout augmenter sa
capacité d'accueil en moins de 24 heures
passant de 18 à 25 lits le jeu des
transferts de patients de régions déjà
sous l'eau vers d'autres comme la
bretagne qui respire encore et bien
amorcée c'est difficile pour eux d'être
à 6 800 km et pour la famille qui est
là-bas de savoir qu'on est ici dans une
région que connaissent pas dans un
hôpital qui ne connaissent pas
connaissent pas les locaux et
connaissent pas le personnel enfin du
fait de savoir que
ils ont été transférés parce qu'ils ont
commises dans plus sûre ajoute
l'angoissent d'un lieu qu'ils
connaissent pas d'une région connaissent
pas plus de patients et plus de patients
locaux ce ne sont pas les seules
différences alarmante que constate le
professeur l'air on a l'impression que
les patients font un petit peu plus
jeunes une dizaine d'années d'âge d'âge
moyen en moins et puis surtout c'est
qu'il ya aussi des patients très jeunes
des patients très jeune sans aucune
comorbidités un des patients de 20 30
ans c'est bien entendu extrêmement rare
mais ça existe et donc ça veut dire
clairement que les mesures barrières
c'est pour tout le monde personne n'est
totalement n'est totalement en sécurité
donc tout le monde doit se protéger
c'est un message qui rompt adler
aimerait bien savoir entendu par plus de
ses concitoyens leur confinement en
version pourtant allégé passe mal pour
beaucoup de français
si une majorité d'entre eux se dit
d'accord avec les mesures sanitaires
imposées par le gouvernement
les restrictions sont aussi mises au
défi tantôt par les élus locaux
tantôt par des commerçants c'est dur sur
le personnel parce que c'est aussi
encore plus dur quand on se rend compte
que les gens ne nous croit pas que les
gens pensent que c'est une dictature de
la santé sur la vie de tous les jours
oui ça c'est usant ça c'est usant c'est
fatiguant physiquement aussi de ne pas
dormir d'avoir pas mal de travail on a
quand même doubler nos équipes plus de
trente mille personnes sont actuellement
hospitalisées en france et près de 5000
d'entre elles sont en réanimation
ces 92 % de la capacité nationale depuis
24 heures on observe tout petit
frétillement de la progression de la
maladie
le covan a virus se répand toujours mais
moins rapidement il est trop tôt pour
dire si la tendance est le résultat du
couvre-feu et du confinement imposées
par l'état et surtout si les mesures en
place suffiront vraiment a cassé la
courbe pour de bon ici marie ève bédard
radio canada brest en bretagne